[Music]
hey guys how's it going we're behind the
scenes here before the live show we're
doing the Gears of War 4 Gears of War 4
live show today I was so excited that I
even packed something in here that I'd
like to show what do you think I have in
here friend change was it so much money
no but I brought my lego video game
player
[Music]
start it make a three-hour show they're
also doing a very long player matches
I'm not sure what game look they finally
decided on but excited opteka infinity
or playing that's happened to later on
in the show
there's also burgers right here
I just need Lunger I would have those
he's getting a tattoo live this is your
first tattoo by the end of the show the
tattoo will hopefully be
[Music]
you have so many friends
Wow one two three
sorry girl
[Applause]
how was the show their show was great
this woman no okay so gears are you
feeling again I mean you complicate I'm
actually about to chapter isn't easily I
haven't had time this week I definitely
begin oh I got early that was online
now everyone's online also the pre-order
early so I'll be on the play yeah let's
go play yay the word if you want this
like in the middle I have no idea
wow this everything's happening I was
cleaning my windows
what wait wait - oh my goodness
this dog
well guys as you may have saw
sporadically the couch has been
delivered but here's the dilemma I don't
know if you guys remember in the video
we even talked about buying the chair
but apparently the chair it's not here
it's not it's not here not really sure
where it is I don't think I'm ever gonna
be able to get this entire place put
together here it is there's a lot of
Maddie's toys everywhere so I think
it'll look better once we have Maddie's
toys all taken care of so now we got to
figure out the chair situation I feel
like I need something over there in that
corner now these the rugs are usually
outside right now because they smell
really bad hopefully they get aired out
and we'll be able to put them in here
where they belong I just got to my order
from GoPro I added a few a couple things
on as you guys may have seen in my inbox
in video the new GoPro Hero 5 is out I
missed on the website that they had in
the dual battery charger which is so
important because even though it is a
new camera the batteries on the GoPro
sometimes do die and if you don't have
an extra it gets really annoying to have
to charge so they also had this it's a
little wind Slayer foam windscreen so
this is new I've never seen GoPro have
these before mommy's making lunch
Francesca's here we already did a shoot
this morning and now we have to go ahead
to the YouTube gaming live show so
that's that's what's happening today a
lot of things are going on I've got this
new lens but it's so heavy
guys look how cute this is
I thought there was no idea was at this
box so like well I'll do like a little
unboxing but then I decided to open it
cuz I know I did it was in this box but
this is so cute
it's a cute little youtuber insider I
can't find any place for this maybe
right on my new coffee table oh yeah
we're also YouTube gaming show Jenna's
not going look at him he's smiling he's
got a smile on his face
yes are you outside
it's really weird getting phone calls on
my wrist hold on
everything's happening see it the show
we are here behind the scenes we are in
a different room this time Diane I
brought us flowers who made these like
look how pretty you did wasn't wasn't
this in your garden this was in my what
is that
Jeffrey excited for the live show today
I'm very excited live with YouTube
gaming episode 2 happening today we're
excited to have you on
Justine you're gonna be playing a game
today can't drive this that's what it's
called it's fun what do you think you're
driving can't honestly a truck I think
the truck I think if the truck and you
drive like on this little map and other
people build the road for you I know
Kang are you gonna build roads or drive
the car I'm not sure how long the
segment I don't know won't see but you
and Kyle boss when one of yous gonna
drive a car when he's gonna build roads
and see how far you guys got cool I'm
excited well good luck on the show and
lots of special guests here I think your
parents are here
I'm thrilled to be here excited ready to
go I mean you know all my life they're
like they're just playing video games
again one thing we want to do we gotta
tell is comes alive with YouTube gaming
we're here we're gonna do a live let's
play for lack of a better term with Kyle
and Justine here it's very simple it's a
cooperative game we're gonna be on the
same team none of us will lay a road and
the other will drive Tetris building a
road and then somebody's driving on your
little touches track because it's got a
little thing up there that tells me
what's coming next you can choose if you
want that one or this one what are you
one side they want to try I want a road
for Hill Road Justine is gonna drive so
he's using the mouse and I'm using the
key here we're using the early access as
you can see some of the stats don't even
work yet but let's let's take a look
here I'm driving see how it works all
right let me know when I when you're
gonna make a row that turns oh I can
this is something where you have to like
you have to keep driving right as your
car explodes just have a choice you
could view they put the garbage pieces
off to the side okay no I'm sorry
go go go go okay we're good we're good
you're just building straightforward
well yeah we got some good luck here
all right here we go
the next one are you ready yeah okay a
little rematch here okay get ready let's
go let's go just let's forget about that
okay we got this now this is happening
live let me build this another
successful show I'm gonna miss you guys
like Thursday I'm not gonna be here for
it just was like can I please go home
shortly okay sounds good now we could go
to dinner that's gonna be there
haven't seen Matt in a couple of days
because he basically just hides in his
room and doesn't come out nothing look
like a man about town he was when
Pokemon go was out Oh
today he's probably vision one of the
longest days ever it started off really
super early with the shoot with
Francesca and then we went in did
another shoot and now we went to dinner
and now we're shopping
somehow I don't know how it we got here
but here we are
oh my god I didn't know that I thought
you were
I assumed in and then I was like oh my
god I don't think this is Jenna that I'm
filming you are you showing them my butt
maybe hey this is a cute outfit this is
something I'd wear except those are a
little too short remember that one time
you bought this t-shirt and went to
check on you is a $200 t-shirt and you
said I don't want it it's looser I've
ever seen it was like an ugly shirt so
it's like this there should have been
like $20 there's no way that this is
gonna be more than $20 I got the check
out she's like that'll be like 9 bucks I
also got a pair of jeans and shoe that
was the only thing you guys the only
thing you got is like it's weird I only
see one item what is so expensive it was
like $300 and I go oh I threw up in
front of this woman then I'm like I feel
like I can't get it anymore hey let's
talk about this lens
oh you copied me huh looks great yeah I
like it but my god it's heavy I don't
think I can do this very G very heavy
I've dropped this thing like 15 times
you get the lens set on there so you
don't mess it up it is very happy that
I'm putting another lens hood on this
shoe I just really love the wide angle
I did too that's why I like to tend to
eight more because it's way what got me
a bag oh no no how does not hold this
he's shredded debatable thanks dangerous
yeah I don't think this is in there all
the way well either way it worked it's
all he's gonna taste it before you bake
it in case it hits the garbage